con tango puede ser una de las ideas más
difíciles de comprender en cuanto se
refiere a mercados futuros pero eso se
debe a que es usado en diferentes
contextos y en cada uno tiene un
significado ligeramente diferente ya sea
que se esté hablando de una persona que
está participando en mercados futuros o
si está describiendo esto un académico
por lo que comenzaremos dando la
definición formal que de hecho es la
teoría la teoría de contango y esto
realmente no lo pueden observar
directamente la teoría del contango dice
que las personas estarán dispuestas a
pagar más para comprar alguna materia
prima en el futuro de lo que es el
precio esperado real de esa materia
prima
cuando hablamos de precios esperados al
menos en teoría si ustedes fueran a
entrevistar a todas las personas que
participan en los mercados futuros y
ustedes le preguntarán cuál es el precio
que ustedes creen que no se en la plata
va a tener en 8 meses y después revisan
todas las respuestas de esa pregunta y
resulta que el precio en el que todos
están más o menos de acuerdo pues es el
precio esperado
caso de 33 dólares teórico al menos para
esta materia prima para la plata en este
ejemplo este es el precio esperado de la
plata en el mercado y pueden ver de esta
curva de precios futuros que el precio
de entrega del contrato futuro de la
plata para entregarse dentro de 8 meses
está por encima del precio esperado y
probablemente está por encima del precio
esperado porque las personas que quieren
comprar la plata dentro de 8 meses no la
quieren comprar ahora y tener que rentar
algún lugar donde guardar la compra de
algún seguro o preocuparse de que se las
vayan a robar ellos prefieren pagar un
precio extra para que se las hagan
llegar en el futuro y esta es la
definición académica correcta para la
teoría del contango la teoría de que el
precio futuro va a ser mayor de lo que
es el precio esperado la gente va a
estar pagando un precio premium para que
le hagan llegar su materia prima en el
futuro
por otra parte en la práctica ustedes
podrán observar que las personas se
refieren al que el mercado está
encontrando y normalmente lo que se
refieren es que están sucediendo una de
dos cosas que están relacionadas pero la
que es más correcta se trata de la idea
de que el precio futuro conforme pase el
tiempo va a converger hacia el precio
esperado lo que ha dibujado aquí es la
curva de precios futuros los precios de
entrega de los diferentes contratos
conforme se alejen en el futuro y aquí
está el precio del mercado actual y aquí
está dibujado como los precios se están
comportando conforme avanza el tiempo y
aquí los colores corresponden al
comportamiento que tienen en el futuro
por ejemplo aquí el magenta aquí en
verde está el contrato que va a
entregarse dentro de cuatro meses el
precio está un poco por debajo de los 35
dólares y aquí vemos su comportamiento
conforme se acerca al cuarto mes su
precio va bajando hasta que se hace
igual al precio esperado de ese momento
si no fuera así las personas podrían
ganar dinero gratis por lo que él
presión entrega dentro de ocho meses
tiene que converger a el precio esperado
eventualmente y como pueden ver que el
precio actual se ha movido mucho pueden
ver estas curvas que van hacia abajo y
que convergen al precio esperado a esto
es algo que las personas normalmente se
refieren cuando dicen que el mercado
está en contango cuando se ve que el
precio de entrega de un contrato futuro
converge hacia abajo al precio esperado
actual
todas estas curvas convergen a su
respectivo precio esperado hacia abajo
es algo que se tiene que observar
conforme pasa el tiempo en general
cuando ustedes tienen este
comportamiento pueden ver que el precio
de entrega futuro es mayor es más alto
que el precio esperado en esa fecha
futura así que el análisis más simple
cuando alguien dice que el mercado está
encontrando es que estamos viendo una
curva de precios futuros que va hacia
arriba y éste también está encontrando
pero eso no es correcto sólo podemos ver
en los movimientos durante el tiempo que
efectivamente se encuentra en contacto